- Well, Danny, you said this
story helped you as a father.
How so?
How did it help you?
- Oh, no question.
You know, communicating with,
I have two boys, a 14 and a 15 year old.
So the power and the
challenge of communicating,
to be present, to find out what they love
and to try to love it too,
so that you have a jumping off point
to have conversations
about things they love,
so that when things they hate happen,
that you have a way in.
- Yeah.
Wow.
It's a very powerful, powerful message.
So I get that.
But what it, did it teach any of you
like anything while you were doing it?
Like Julianne, did it teach you anything?
- I think it just reminds you to
connect to other people and to
really try to see them.
'Cause that's what everybody really wants
and needs is to be seen
by another human being.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And connection in general, I feel like,
especially as a parent,
I'm just listening to you say that,
and I was like, it's so hard,
it's easy for us to be at work
and on our phone and on
emails and stuff like that.
It's very important to keep connected.
I think especially, we know that more
now than ever, says isolation.
And so, Amy what about you?
- Oh absolutely.
I echo what Danny and Julianne said
that as a parent, it's
such a great reminder
to stay connected with your kids
and as a friend and as family member,
just reaching out to everybody,
making sure everybody's okay.
Just really keeping those
lines of communication open.
- Absolutely.
I think that that's really
important about connection too.
I have a question though, Ben,
because if you started
this years ago on Broadway,
I mean, I'm sure you
learned something then,
but was there something that
kind of hit you differently
while doing the movie at a different age
and different place in your life?
- I think so.
I mean, I think I've, as
I've grown a little bit
and evolved and become like a sort of
pseudo adult now a little bit,
I find that I share a lot more with Evan
than I thought I did in terms of
Evan is very afraid of the
kind of awkward, painful,
uncomfortable conversations
that are necessary
to kind of break through and get to
something deep and get
to a real connection.
I think that can be such a deterrent for,
for such meaningful relationships because
you're just afraid of
those first interactions
or that jumping off that cliff.
And I think I have that too.
I'm a kind of a fearful kind of a
non-confrontational person in many ways.
And so playing him and seeing
the mistakes that he makes and
all that that keeps him from,
I think it's really taught
me and encouraged me
to just push myself off that cliff
whenever possible and force myself to
have those conversations
and be in those situations
and kind of muscle through them
because I know how much
meaning and connection
is on the other side of that.
- Absolute, well said, okay.